what would you say if we told you that
humanity is currently making a
collaborative effort to engineer the
perfect super bug a bug that could kill
hundreds of millions of people well it
is happening right now we are in the
process of creating a super bacterium
bacteria are among the oldest living
things on this planet the smallest thing
we still consider life they are masters
of survival and can be found everywhere
most bacteria are harmless to us your
body hosts trillions of them and they
help you to survive but others can
invade your body spread quickly and kill
you millions of people used to die as a
result of bacterial infections until we
developed a super weapon antibiotics
together with vaccinations antibiotics
revolutionized medicine and saved
millions of lives antibiotics kill the
vast majority of susceptible bacteria
fairly quickly leaving only a small
group of survivors that are immune
system then deals with easily how do
antibiotics do this imagine a bacterium
as a very complex machine with thousands
of complex processes going on that keep
it alive and active antibiotics disrupt
this complex machinery for example by
interfering with its metabolism slowing
down their growth significantly so they
are less of a threat other antibiotics
attack DNA and prevent it from being
replicated which stops bacteria from
multiplying ultimately killing them all
by simply ripping the outer layer of the
bacteria to shreds so that their
insights spill out and they die quickly
all of this without bothering body cells
but now evolution is making things more
complicated by pure random chance a
small minority of the bacteria invading
your body might have evolved a way to
protect themselves for example by
intercepting the antibiotics and
changing the molecule so it becomes
harmless all by investing energy in
pumps that ejects the antibiotics before
they can do damage a few immune bacteria
are not that big a deal because the
immune system can take care of them but
if they escape they might spread their
immunity how can bacteria spread
immunity first of all bacteria have two
kinds of DNA the chromosome and small
free-floating parts called plasmids they
can hug each other and exchange those
plasmids to exchange useful abilities
this way immunity can be spread quickly
through a population or in a process
called transformation bacteria can
of dead bacteria and collects DNA pieces
this even works between different
bacterial species and can lead to
superbugs bacteria that are immune to
multiple antibiotics a variety of
superbugs already exists in the world
especially hospitals and other perfect
breeding grounds for them
humans have short memories the horrors
of the pre-antibiotic era have been
forgotten today we treat this powerful
medicine as a commodity instead of as
the game-changing achievement of science
that it is this has led to a strange
disconnect hundreds of millions of
people still don't have access to
antibiotics in developing countries
while in other parts of the world
antibiotics are prescribed too freely
and taken without care
antibiotics should be a last resort drug
not something you take because you're
cold is annoying another serious problem
is antibiotic use in meat production at
any particular point in time humanity
holds between 20 and 30 billion animals
as livestock to make meat cheaper many
animals are held in horrible conditions
in very tight spaces and in unhygenic
conditions the perfect breeding ground
for a disease so many animals are given
antibiotics to kill as many bacteria as
possible and prevent them from getting
sick because a cheeseburger has to cost
a dollar unsurprisingly as a result of
this system we have created more and
more bacteria that are resistant to
antibiotics to counteract this we use
different antibiotics and we have
another secret weapon there are specific
antibiotics that are used to wipe out
bacteria that have developed resistance
there are strict rules for using these
to avoid the creation of a super
bacterium or so we thought in late 2015
scary news arrived from China resistance
against colistin a last-ditch antibiotic
had been discovered Kalista is an old
drug and was rarely used because it can
damage the liver so there was little
resistance against it which made it a
great antibiotic of last resort for
certain complex infections that occur in
hospitals to fight bacteria that have
become immune to a whole bunch of other
drugs
bacterial resistance to Kalista is very
very bad news it might destroy a last
line of defense and lead to a whole lot
of dead people how could this happen
millions of animals in Chinese pig farms
have been given callused in a few years
resistant bacteria developed spreading
first from animal to animal and then to
humans without being noticed on an
average day there are over 100,000
flights on earth kind of connecting
every human on the planet by creating
the modern world we have also built the
infrastructure for a dangerous pandemic
still we don't need to panic just yet
bacteria evolved humans to research new
antibiotics are developed as old ones
become obsolete technology is advancing
every day the problem is real and
serious but the fight is far from over
if humanity plays its cards right civil
bugs might turn out to be not very super
after all this video was made possible
by viewers support on patreon.com and a
grant from the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation if you want to support us to
make more videos you can buy a corsage
poster or mug or donate on patreon thank
you so much for your help